thank you for being a friend
cher is using her iconic voice to
celebrate america's golden girl the late
betty white and it's giving us all the
feels
the 75 year old songtrist took to her
instagram on friday and shared a snippet
of her rendition of the golden girls
theme song thank you for being a friend
she captioned the post quote every
friend is golden isn't that wonderful
thank you for being a friend
cher's take on the classic will honor
the legendary actress during monday's
nbc special celebrating betty white
america's golden girl
[Music]
thank you for being a friend was
originally written and recorded by
andrew gold in 1978 cynthia fee would
later cover the track a version that
would endure beyond the sitcom's run on
nbc from 1985 until 1992 and fun fact
cher sang her version of the song on the
original golden girls stage in hollywood
stage 5 where the series was taped yes
that is true cher is just one of the
many celebs and public figures who will
pay tribute to betty white during
monday's special president biden will
make an appearance as well as jay leno
ellen degeneres drew barrymore jimmy
fallon and more earlier this month betty
appeared in a heartwarming video shared
posthumously on social media i just want
to thank you all for your love and
support in the video's caption her
assistant explained that the video was
meant to be shared for her 100th
birthday i just want to thank you all
for your love and support
over the years
thank you so much
and
stick around
according to a death certificate
obtained by e.t the beloved golden girl
star suffered a stroke six days before
her death on new year's eve her cause of
death was ruled as a cerebrovascular
accident
we were sort of old friends the minute
we were introduced after betty's passing
it spoke with her dear friend actress
jennifer love hewitt who met betty on
the set of their hallmark hall of fame
movie the lost valentine in 2011.
jennifer reflected on the kind of person
betty was and her legacy
when betty and i worked together it was
instant love for me i think she had to i
had to grow on her a little bit but it
was instant love for me and um when we
wrapped i gave her a tiffany's necklace
i gave her a little heart diamond
necklace and i told her that i wanted
her to take a piece of my heart with her
um because i didn't know you know
sometimes you work with people in
hollywood and then you never see them
again right i didn't know that we would
be able to become and stay such good
friends anyway
um betty wore that necklace every single
day
for 11 years and she had it on with her
when she passed um and
a friend of hers called and said you
know we have to take the knuckles off um
but it was the first time in 11 years
that she took that off and that's who
betty was she knew
that for me it meant something to give
her my heart and she wore it and every
time she heard my name she would kiss it
and she would always make sure that i
knew she still had it on and um
it was just it's just beautiful to me
that it was with her um in her last
moment um and that she had my heart with
her and she always will um but i think
it's a testament to who she is because
lots of people are given you know gifts
from people along the way and they end
up in a drawer they end up in a jewelry
box or whatever but she really knew what
it meant to me to give it to her
and in return it meant something to her
and she kept it with her and it's just
one of the greatest gifts i've ever been
given personally in my life is knowing
that it really
touched her
[Music]